hi everyone this is Philip from that
stock religion as you may notice the
camera quality is as good as it usually
is maybe you've seen on my channel that
my camera lens actually broke a few days
ago so I'm doing this very spontaneous
video with a cell phone camera and I
should have the regular camera fixed
pretty soon so today I thought I'd do a
kind of Q&A video so I asked so my
patrons my patreon page which I will
link to in the description and so I've
received some questions that I will do
my best to answer now this kind of video
is very unusual for this channel it's
very unusual for me I'm used to being
very academic and objective as much as I
can and scientific and so being more
personal with you feels unusual but I
think it's also a very good thing to
have more of personal interaction with
you as an audience and if you want to
get the opportunity to ask me questions
for these Q&A videos in the future I
suggest you become a patron and again I
will leave that link in the description
and also in the future I might do videos
where you give all of you the
opportunity to ask questions so so Conor
D one of my patrons asks the question
what spurred you to start making YouTube
videos I'm actually kind of proud of the
beginnings of this channel it feels like
a very noble cause very noble beginning
it started about three years ago when I
was studying the Philosopher's happen to
fail under Lucien philosopher from the
12th century and his text high opinion
son and I hadn't read the actual text
yet but I was looking for general
information about it so I was looking on
YouTube and other pages and but there
was there was nothing there was no
videos no videos of any good quality at
least and no real information anywhere
and so I had to give that idea up
basically
but then when I had actually read the
text itself and studied it more deeply I
realized that maybe maybe I should make
that video that I wished was on YouTube
when I was looking for information and
so I did so that became
the first video which I released on
knife I put it up on my personal channel
called feeling poem which is my name and
then just a few months later I made
another video on even Hal dune and both
of these videos were very successful a
lot of people seem to appreciate them a
lot and so this kind of because accede
to the idea that maybe I should make
channel or start making more videos
dedicated to this kind of thing at the
time I was a master student and the
study of religions and and was pretty
knowledgeable at least in my particular
field and so I thought maybe I should
make a channel where I shared this
knowledge because I thought were felt at
the time that YouTube was lacking in
good trustworthy academic content
regarding religion and related subjects
and so I created the channel let's talk
religion specifically dedicated to this
to filling that gap that I felt was on
YouTube of course since then there's
been a lot of other channels as well
that are really great but we all have
our own niches and our subjects that we
are specialized in but in case that's
that's how how I create this channel
that's the reason why I started making
these videos question number two what
has been your favorite subject of
research today that's a very really good
question very difficult question to
answer because I'm the kind of person
because I'm the kind of person who group
I'm interested in everything and
everything I hear about everything I
read I'm a very curious person and so
it's hard to just choose one subject as
I've said in some videos I have
specialized particularly in Sufism and
Islam and so obviously I am very
interested in those subjects and I think
that's a very interesting subject to
study but in particular probably because
I'm also a musician I have been very
interested in music and how music
relates to religion in different ways
for example Sufism of course has some
very strong musical traditions for
example the year the ritual known as
Samar or audition in which music is a
very prominent component and dance and
so
aspects of religion Sufism and other
religions where music and religious
ritual or mysticism always meet that has
been an incredibly fascinating subject
that I loved to to study and still do
I wrote my bachelor's thesis on this
kind of subject and I am planning to do
more on that in the future and of course
I will be making videos on that subject
a lot I have a lot of videos planned
that that will talk about music in
different ways and how it relates to
religion so I look forward to that but
that that's also that's definitely one
of the things that I've been most
interested in generally and the kind of
personality I'm having nerdy personality
so I like to get really deep into some
incredibly niche subject a very specific
thing so even though I really enjoy you
know contemporary theories sociological
psychological theories and how religion
relates to society and all this is
something I do as well but there's
always that part inside of me that just
wants to sit in some dark library
somewhere and read an old text hold
philosophical or mystical texts and so
yeah those kinds of things I guess so to
give you the short answer would be the
things that I've enjoyed in a way the
most and still enjoy studying question
number three are you religious this is a
question I get a lot I don't know why a
lot of you guys seem interested in my
personal beliefs I guess that's natural
I tend to avoid this question because it
makes me a little uncomfortable
I guess because it's it's more personal
than I am used to be also what does the
word religious me it all depends on how
we define that word in academia it seems
like all we do is talk about how we
shouldn't define different terms and
that can be kind of tedious but it is
very important what does religious even
mean if I say yes I am religious that
has certain connotations that you will
have certain ideas or preconceived
notions about what that says about me
you my first
what I do in my life and so I try to
avoid saying that I am religious or not
religious if you were to ask me do I
believe in God I would usually say yes
but then even then I would have to
usually explain myself here in Sweden
there's kind of a stigma against
believing in God it's seen that's
rational and so I feel like I sometimes
have to if I say I believe in God and I
said well God to me means this and that
and so so it's a complex subject I'll
probably just leave it there and maybe
explain it further in the future when I
have a more thorough answer to give you
but am i religious it depends on what
you mean by that sir okay last question
for this video what sparked your
interest in religious studies I've
always been interested in religion
mythology in history and archaeology
it's a very fascinating subject you're
studying both historical subjects old
religions old civilizations and all this
but also today how religion affects
society religion impacts our lives and
and so on I didn't actually start my
academic career as as a student of
religions the first subject that I
studied was actually political science
not message oh because I wanted to
become a politician or anything but I
was looking to maybe work in NGOs or I
was so I had studied political science
for three semesters that I needed some
extra points to get my bachelor's degree
because I wasn't doing a full program
but individual courses and so I thought
well religion is interesting like I'm
interested in religion and so I took a
course in religion this is in 2015 and
just I think a few weeks into that
course I realized huh this may be this
was when I was supposed to be doing all
this time
it just piqued my interest and my
fascination on such a level and also not
sound like I'm bragging but I was also
they
good at it it just you just felt right
to me and so I kept studying that
feeling today I have a master's degree
and I'm looking to through I'm applying
currently for PhD positions so obviously
this is something that I'm very
interested in and then I want to
dedicate a large portion of my time to I
think I also realized as I was studying
religion not just how fascinating it is
in itself what its historical sort of
philosophical or metaphysical aspects
that's one thing but also because I
realized even more than I had before how
much society has impacted our society
our world generally how it still impacts
our world and our societies and our
lives basically how important religion
is to people in the world regardless if
we realize it or not but in spite of
this incredible importance it felt like
there is so much misconceptions about
religion people know very little about
how religion actually works what what
the history and the ideas of a lot of
these religions are it just felt like a
very important subject also for our
current world to understand religion
better means that we can talk to each
other better it means that we can
hopefully and eventually if we know more
about each other and each other's
religious traditions for example and
that opens up for more conversation and
more tolerance and so I just felt like
on the one hand is way very interesting
and fascinating subject on many
different ways but also that is a very
important subject and one that is very
beneficial both personally but also to
on a wider societal level so I think
that's in a nutshell why religious
studies seems so something that I wanted
to keep doing and that's all I have time
for today I hope you enjoyed that little
Q&A if you want more videos like this I
suggest you like the video and maybe
leave a comment telling me if you want
more I will probably doing more of these
especially with my patrons and hopefully
as soon as I get my camera fixed I will
start
making the proper videos again it's
gonna take a little longer than usual I
try to release one video a week or at
least one every two weeks but this next
one might take a little longer so be
patient it is coming pretty soon until
then I hope you're all doing well and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]